i find that interesting that you say you
leave the camera out and you meet with
the quote subjects a few times
once that camera's out did does
everything just change the way we were
talking about off camera for a moment
just how
it just changes like the whole dynamic
of the room almost yeah no i mean that's
a great question about
how does the camera affect your subjects
uh and it's it's a question that i think
about a lot um
because
for our films we always want to try to
get as close to the story as we can
without changing the story
and so
that's too hard to do when you have a
camera in a room
whether you're making a movie or whether
you're just taking pictures at a
birthday party i mean cameras tend to
affect people they they act a little
differently when they're around
that said
we spend a lot of time with our subjects
and i think after a while they just get
used to the camera being in the room
and and
it starts to feel i think pretty natural
to them
um
we did something on if you build it that
we had never done before which is we put
cameras into the hands
of the kids that we were telling the
story about
so we asked them to shoot for us
when we weren't there and even to shoot
while we were there they were they were
always shooting flip cams or
iphones and a lot of that footage is in
the movie
and that that was great too because i
think it allowed them to understand what
we do
and also to sort of demystify
the process of of making a film
um nowadays everyone's a filmmaker and
we have a we we started a film festival
here at our local grammar school
that um
where literally like first and second
grade kids
make their own movies
and put them show them in the film
festival
so this idea of
filmmaking
is it's so broad now and so many people
i think take part in that
that
it's it's really
it's really been interesting to watch
that there's there's just some great
stories being made nowadays by people
who never really traditionally have been
thought of as filmmakers
you